قال رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان بلاده
تدرس باهتمام خطه التسويه التي اقترحتها
الصين حول الوضع في اوكرانيا واكد انفتاح
موسكو دوما على عمليه التفاوض بوتين وفي
لقاء جمعه بنظيره الصيني
وصف المواقف الصينيه بالمتوازنه في
القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه بدوره قال
الرئيس الصيني تشيجين بنج ان بلده مهتمه
بتطوير العلاقه مع روسيا واصفا اياها
بالشريك الاستراتيجي واضاف ان الدولتين
لديهما اهداف متشابهه
اطلعنا بتمعون على اقتراحاتكم بشان تسويه
الازمه الحاده في اوكرانيا وبالطبع ستكون
لدينا الامكانيه لبحث المساله ندرك تماما
انكم تنطلقون من مبدا العداله واحترام اسس
القانون الدولي ومبادئه وانتم تعلمون اننا
دائما منفتحون على عمليه التفاوض سنناقشه
كافه هذه المسائل ومقترحاتكم والتي
نحترمها